[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera anch'io vi parlerò di dati
sono dati differenti sono dati che
riguardano la nostra persona il nostro
comportamento e lo vorrei fare partendo
da una domanda dove andiamo in vacanza
questa è una domanda che ci poniamo
spesso una domanda che ci poniamo almeno
una due volte l'anno
i più fortunati anche 5 10 volte altre
no ci pone una scelta dove passiamo al
nostro periodo di relax il periodo di
fuori di lavoro periodo per scoprire il
mondo per scoprire altre colture questa
domanda se lo fanno e propongono sempre
più persone infatti sono sempre più
persone che stanno viaggiando i trend
predittivi a livello 2003 all'anno 2030
sono ormai già superati facciamo circa
tre anni in avanti rispetto al trend il
turismo cresce e non smetterà continuerà
a crescere come avete sentito il mio
accento io sono veneziano sono di
venezia è l'unica cosa che pensavo
fermasse il turismo fosse l'acqua alta
non è così
e successo poco tempo fa quello che
sapete è continuamente flotte di turisti
continuano ad arrivare a venezia nella
nostra destinazione nella nostra città
ma quali sono le città e le destinazioni
più sognate quali sono quelle che
desideriamo visita
una ricerca di trave supermarket
rielabora tutte le ricerche online fatte
dagli utenti utilizza le keywords travel
viaggi vacanza eva plastici e
classificare per le aree geografiche
l'interesse degli utenti e vediamo che
l'italia il nostro pianeta paese è il
primo tra le ricerche
sembra impossibile ma italia batte
spagna almeno in termini turistici di
ricerca cosa che invece sportivamente
facciamo sempre più fatica
seguono australia grecia e spagna
ma torniamo a un attimo il processo che
ci permette di rispondere a questa
domanda
questo processo che gli studiosi
chiamano e di pre esperienza turistica
po di pre tour a due fasi principali il
dream cioè noi sogniamo di andare in
vacanza abbiamo il bisogno di andare in
vacanza e il cius scegliamo dove andare
dove alloggiare e che cosa fare queste
due fasi sono influenzate sembrano in
più da internet nei social network e da
come abbiamo visto dei dati ormai nella
fase dream tutto ci sta influenzando ci
influenza la serie tv che stiamo vedendo
ci influenza le stories del 9 del nostro
influenzo il preferito
influenzano le immagini e video che
vediamo nei social i racconti degli
amici
i racconti dei parenti e poi nella fase
continua questa influenza l'influenza
della parte della community quando
andiamo a vedere e leggere le recensioni
per capire dove alloggiare dove mangiare
in una destinazione quale accomodation
scegliere e poi ovviamente in questa
fase la fase del susa ci influenza
ancora una cosa molto importante ci
pensa il prezzo e quindi utilizziamo
sempre di più canali che comparano il
prezzo per scegliere l'esperienza
migliore a basso prezzo già facendo
queste due prime fasi
stiamo producendo dati stiamo costruendo
un backlog un dataset diciamo di dati
sulle nostre preferenze
questi dati vengono esplosi nella fase
dopo la fase dell'esperienza la fase
della del vero e proprio viaggio durante
appunto la mia visita in una
destinazione produco viaggi per quanto
riguarda la mobilità
produco viaggi per quanto riguarda il
check in e mail ai che le mie foto più
che posto nei social cc ci troviamo
davanti a un data sunami nazionali per
quanto riguarda il mondo del turismo
e questo dato al suo nanì e gestito però
dalle macchine non è gestito
direttamente da noi sono le macchine in
questo caso degli algoritmi che li
lavano questo processo che abbiamo fatto
per sviluppare un processo circolare
sono alla ricerca della mia destinazione
e lascio dei dati che noi chiamiamo
digital footprints delle tracce digitali
che mi che aiutano l'algoritmo a capire
i miei desideri si aggiorna aggiorna le
mie preferenze e dall'impasto questa
informazione ha delle piattaforme web
che suggeriscono che cosa fare dove
visitare dove andare dove dormire che
esperienza fare e queste piattaforme in
modalità push arrivano di nuovo da me
con gli stessi canali che io cercavo la
la destinazione e questo processo
continua e questo processo continua a
essere circolare ma comunque ottica
questi algoritmi queste macchine
alimentano questo processo è un ottica
di guadagno è un ottica di fatturato
voglio vendere una fase mite turistica
voglio vendere un'esperienza voglio
vendere la mia destinazione che meglio
di altre
oppure guarda con gli occhi del turista
del turista che sognano destinazione
quindi è tutto perfetto
la destinazione è luogo migliori che
possono che posso raggiunti
e quindi guarda con degli occhi che
mostrano questo e quindi la destinazione
migliore con la più bella quella da di
sicuro visitare da andare a vedere ma di
sicuro non mostra questo è niente meno
questo algoritmo non riesce a capire
cosa è meglio per la destinazione esce
capire solo che cosa può essere utile e
può essere facilmente piazzato nel
mercato in modo da vendere
questo è questa esperienza e questo
processo circolare se continua così non
viene gestito da un processo circolare
che diventa un circolo vizioso la
destinazione che tutti vogliono andare a
visitare sarà sempre più promossa sarà
sempre più acquistata sarà sempre più a
circa cercata da altri turisti ed i
potenziali turisti e questo circolo
vizioso avrà un impatto sempre più forte
su quella destinazione
questo crea però appunto delle
divergenze tra delle divergenze che
negli ultimi anni hanno visto questi
fenomeni
l'over turismo e l'under to reason
l'over turismo
si parla spesso di over turismo negli
ultimi anni collegando l'italia ma
l'italia non ha problema di copertura
del terzolo determinate destinazioni
hanno problemi di over turismo firenze
roma venezia hanno problemi decisamente
di overture iso ma solo in determinati
periodi
non sempre e ci sono migliaia di altre
destinazioni che si ritrovano invece
nell'altra situazione
la citazione dell'under prigione forse
però a questo punto la scelta da
prendere non è quella di gestire il
turismo e di verificare che cosa può
essere piazzato nel mercato turistico ma
è quella di pensare alla capacità alla
capacità e quindi pensa alle
destinazioni che vivono situazioni di
overcapacity dove la capacità di
accogliere i turisti deve essere
limitata deve essere controllata
ci deve essere un limite un numero
chiuso a volte per tutelare e la
sostenibilità della destinazione e altre
destinazioni invece che hanno tanto da
esprimere e quindi devono sono in
situazioni di under capacity che devono
essere promosse che devono essere
sviluppate che devono far rete tra di
loro o la community stessa deve far fare
emergere questa capacità in espressa
dalla destinazione quello che stiamo
facendo appunto e cercare di elaborare
degli algoritmi che siano più vicino
alle persone praticamente sappiamo ormai
tutti i comportamenti delle persone
durante il suo viaggio
pensate che grazie alle celle
telefoniche
abbiamo un record quindi un'informazione
al minuto di tutte le persone che hanno
un telefono cellulare acceso
quindi li possiamo tracciare nel
territorio nel territorio italiano
la loro visita continuamente e capiamo
le loro preferenze del loro loro schemi
di visita quello che stiamo facendo
appunto e cercate di fare training a
questa macchina a questo algoritmo per
essere più vicino alle persone per
essere più vicino al territorio
l'algoritmo quindi deve essere sensibile
deve essere sostenibile deve essere più
vicino all'ambiente per tutelare le
bellezze storiche artistiche e naturali
che abbiamo ma deve essere anche vicino
alle persone e soprattutto alle persone
che vivono in quella destinazione che
stiamo visitando i residenti la comunità
locale quindi l'invito che vi faccio
quando dovete rispondere alla prima
domanda che vi ho fatto il dove andiamo
in vacanza nei tenere a mente anche
questo è di non andare in vacanza solo
perché quel destino di quella
distrazione di moda o perché su un
social vedo sempre più amici ho sempre
più persone che stanno visitarne con la
destinazione la ma dovete anche voi a
tenere a mente questo processo la
sostenibilità dell'impatto
a volte può essere cruciale per la
sostenibilità del turismo in italia e
per sviluppare soprattutto quello che
ora si trova in una situazione di under
capacity del turno
grazie
[Applauso]